j'avais été accusé madame Montiel de
liker des messages euh
les messages qui disaient du mal de
Mathieu et qui vous suçait qui qui vous
sucer du verbe suicier
vous à la présentation de TPMP alors
cette affaire ne regarde que vous deux
mais il semblerait que de plus en plus
de personnes
soit d'accord avec Mathieu
et que vous ayez pris le Boulard le
melon
vous pose cette question à vous
chroniqueur à vous chez vous Bernard
Montiel a-t-il pris la grosse tête petit
récap et on aura ensuite des témoignages
[Rires]
alors qu'il est à la tête de l'émission
à succès TPMP people depuis maintenant
trois semaines Bernard Montiel n'a pas
attendu pour être au coeur d'une
polémique alors qu'un ancien chroniqueur
a souhaité mettre les points sur les i
la barre sur l'été ou encore la petite
queue sur le cul plusieurs témoignages
viennent corroborer le fait que celui
qui incarnait Patrick Saint balle dans
Sous le soleil aurait pris la grosse
tête pour preuve ce témoignage pas du
tout anonyme du président Macron c'est
un mythomane mais qui retourne montrer
des vidéos de chiens qui pètent
bouffondre ou encore ce témoignage
anonyme d'une collaboratrice au début il
voulait juste du café dans sa loge
ensuite il a exigé des lingettes
autobronzantes et maintenant il veut
qu'on imite le chien qui pète en sa
présence pour je cite ne pas oublier qui
a fait les belles heures de TF1
ce témoignage pas de ouf anonyme Bernard
Montiel c'est un demi-siècle de carrière
carrière formidable c'est vrai que c'est
un peu le melon de la bande quoi il se
prend vraiment pour une star un Tarba un
vrai ter-basse mondial révélation choc
témoignage incriminant selon vous
Bernard Montiel a-t-il pris la grosse
tête
à 18h50 pour répondre ensuite c'est la
question que je vous pose à vous chez
vous et bien sûr à vous merci
[Musique]
Guillaume
depuis quelques jours Bernard demande à
se faire appeler la Beyoncé de la TNT
et voilà je tiens à dire qu'il a pris un
melon certain il appelle régulièrement
des palaces pour avoir des chutes
présidentielles parce qu'il dit que ça
soit une image des palaces que lui
vienne dans les hôtels donc clairement
oui c'est un grand OUI Daniel je connais
depuis 30 ans c'est 30 ans de melon
[Rires]
en fait
d'Isabelle forcément Isabelle Adjani
enfin il fait du même droping c'est une
seconde nature et moi je suis au
spectacle dans la loge c'est-à-dire que
oui Isabelle m'a appelé elle me supplie
pour que je sois dans son film mais bon
j'ai dit non voilà ça ça c'est Bernard
Montiel non stop donc moi c'est un
spectacle et ça n'empêche pas je l'adore
et qu'il est très sympathique je pensais
pas que vous diriez la vérité
moi je pense que comme beaucoup de
personnes
âgées
[Rires]
bien Twitter donc il sait pas rendu
compte que c'était un retour donc je
pense que c'est un accident de parcours
bien sûr
alors je pense que c'est un accident
Dieu je lui en ai parlé tout à l'heure
et vraiment j'ai pas compris je lui en
ai je lui en ai voulu parce que je dis
comment tu as pu être aussi bête pour
faire un truc comme ça
c'est vraiment c'est on est très proche
de moi
je lui ai dit que que publiquement ça
m'avait étonné de sa part qu'il ait fait
quelque chose comme ça et il m'a
expliqué pourquoi il l'avait fait alors
après chacun on tire ses conclusions
mais voilà il était peiné de base
alors j'ai une réaction sur mes bottines
de toute la famille
dans un instant Géraldine maillet pour
vous si c'est non ben non parce qu'en
fait effectivement comme la vie Daniel
je pense que il y a une telle longévité
dans la carrière de Bernard Montiel
quand en fait si on n'a pas la grosse
tête si on n'est pas un peu sûr de soi
un peu comme vous en fait on peut pas
durer comme ça
TOI tu me mets dans la sauce
comme ça je pense qu'il faut quand même
les doses de self festive de confiance
en
soi ici
il y a des degrés Bernard il est au
niveau
vous vous êtes plutôt pastèque
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
Géraldine je comprends ce que tu dis je
comprends quoi
la carrière pendant longtemps je pense
que tous les grands présentateurs qu'on
a reçu ici ils avaient tous des ego
c'est moi
mon nombril mon nombril mon nombril et
tout ça tout ce qu'on a reçu
une carrière incroyable dérogerait à la
règle moi je trouve que c'est insuppa et
je vais vous dire et je non parce que je
rebondis sur ce qu'a dit minime je n'ai
pas franchement je pense que je suis le
non
tous les animateurs non mais vous êtes
vous cherchez vos mots
je suis désolé je suis sûrement que j'ai
pas le mot Hugo dis la vérité
de soi c'est positif tu peux entraîner
les autres avec soi quand on est sur le
soir
oh bah il avait déjà démarré avant
mais je suis déjà allé voir
je suis désolé je m'occupe toi après
parce que j'ai pas aimé cette attaque il
y a une différence quand même c'est pas
parce que on a le melon qu'on va
dénigrer les autres voilà c'est c'est
deux choses différentes la question que
vous pose vous posez pour Bernard je
vois pas trop le rapport parce qu'il
dénigre les autres personnes
moi j'adore Bernard j'ai regardé dans
vidéo gag et tout mais c'est fait ça
commence bien il a le melon la photo
déjà juste mettre la photo mais moi
comme je livre dans son quartier il a il
a dit aux éboueurs laisser plus les
poubelles devant chez moi parce que
quand je sors je ne veux pas voir les
poubelles
incroyable
ouais mais c'est Bernard Montiel
qui voulait mettre une terrasse de
restaurant Il vous mettez pas votre
terrasse ici parce que les gens vont
parler en bas de chez moi vous la
décalez sur la gauche je le croise le
matin je dis ça ça lui Bernard tu as vu
j'étais content de te voir tu m'as dit
désolé mec j'ai pas le temps de parler
avec toi tu es parti
tu m'as dit NON NON casse pas les
couilles
donc oui il a un peu le la grosse tête
Bernard ça y est c'est
la vedette je crois que c'est l'âge je
crois que c'est une question
aimable qui n'a pas parlé sur ce sujet
moi
[Rires]
j'étais dans un film avec Baby moi moi
je vais l'arrêter oui
ce type est une horreur
et que c'est un très mauvais service de
l'avoir mis à la tête de TPMP people il
était à la chaîne animaux confidentiel
il a animé ses petits trucs que personne
ne regardait et là il était premier sur
les écureuils
entrer dans la loge il est insupportable
il me dit plus bonjour Cyril fait
quelque chose retirez lui des émissions
c'est impossible on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça je me fais pour une
fois le porte-parole des équipes Montiel
est devenu insupportable soit tu changes
Bernard soit tu t'en vas mais c'est
impossible
on a un témoignage anonyme également de
ma mère
Bernard Montiel ne salue pas les fans
dans la rue
il a le melon le melon il l'a c'est
terrible il est terrible et c'est vrai
que voilà même des gens qui vous
prennent des gens que vous avez le melon
exactement
vous êtes aujourd'hui sous le feu des
critiques je sais c'est violent en plus
mais je croyais avoir des amis ici alors
les amis ici
tu verras assez vite que c'est pas le
bon terrain est une grande famille c'est
ce qu'on dit tu t'es trompé mon chéri
donc aujourd'hui
est-ce que
tu considères que tu as le melon
oui oui oui
parce qu'en plus vous voyez j'ai rien
demandé tout me tombe dessus parce qu'on
sait que j'ai la grâce et je sais tenir
une émission que on se dit tiens voilà
il avait nous aider il vient au secours
ils veulent notre secours je suis là je
réponds toujours présent je suis là je
suis un bon soldat vous voyez et c'est
vrai que je le fais avec ta langue Rio
et Charles
quand on a une valeur sûre comme moi on
garde un peu de côté dès qu'il y a un
truc pas la peine Bernard Montiel et il
arrive souriant magnifique et c'est
agréable
je vous comprends que vous êtes devenu
fou
[Applaudissements]
je savais en plus Siri une question
d'âge
ça sentit ça commence à frapper un peu
sur la tranche
[Musique]
maintenant je m'en fous maintenant non
je suis très heureux il faut que tu
payes la maison là-bas que tu as acheté
là ouais de faire ce que je fais la
piscine ça douille
bah non mais c'est vrai faut plus la
remplir mais non non mais c'est vrai que
arrivé à 66 ans vous vous en foutez un
peu de tout tout en respectant les
autres si on peut voilà non non mais
c'est vrai que forcément au bout de 40
ans presque 40 ans de carrière on s'est
dit quand même c'est chiant encore là
c'est très curieux vous voyez ah oui
c'est curieux il y a des raisons
vous demandez pourquoi vous me gardez
vous alors
et le beau temps ça va être encore plus
dur ça va ça va ok sympa
voilà exactement tu es payé
revendications
donc la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine et
à la semaine prochaine tu es tranquille
c'est la finale femme
ça marche mais ça se finito la finale
femme ça démarre à 15h à 17h30 tout est
plié
[Rires]
comme d'habitude les infos people
parce que justement on attend toujours
le dernier moment pour avoir les
meilleurs infos des Exclusives tu peux
pas savoir lundi si tu veux faire samedi
c'est vrai sinon c'est très grave et ben
oui j'attends on n'a pas les infos mais
tu participes vraiment les missions les
laboration des missions et tout ah oui
on en parle beaucoup avec Agatha roulant
qui est formidable
et c'est toi qui prends les décisions
on en parle ensemble je suggère des
choses alors ne suggère plus rien
si je peux te demander un service voilà
c'est juste pour la chaîne je
t'expliquerai